le tandem epst et maxwell fait frémir
dans son ancien quartier de manhattan
des gens mauvais qu'ils doivent payer 17
hommes issus de la cruauté pure qui
devait être révélé selon cette résidente
et tant mieux grâce à des mouvements
commis tout ça arrive à m on arrive à à
les identifier à les condamner ghislaine
maxwell est un pur produit de la haute
société britannique
fille d'un magnat de la presse
mégalomane diplômé d'oxford avec la
royauté dans son carnet
d'adressés dans les années 1990
ghislaine maxwell rencontre le
richissime homme d'affaires jefferies
obstine ensemble ils côtoient donald
trump bill clinton et le prince andrew
elle baigne dans l'opulence en échange
de quoi
ghislaine maxwell aurait recruté des
adolescentes aussi jeune que 14 ans pour
livrer à son partenaire prétendu
prédateurs sexuels que ce soit ici au
manoir de jeff reed sting près de
central park à son ranch ou à son
domaine de palm beach gilad maxwell
aurait attiré des filles souvent
vulnérables sous prétexte d'offrir des
massages à l'homme d'affaires en échange
de quelques centaines de dollars mais
une fois arrivés ici le piège ce serait
refermée sur elle
ghislaine maxwell aurait elle-même
participé à des agressions sexuelles
selon la poursuite la femme de 59 ans
accusé de crime sexuel concernant quatre
adolescentes clame son innocence son
procès devant jury pourrait être la
dernière chance de faire la lumière sur
les crimes de jefferies obstine
millionnaire puissant mort en prison un
mois après son arrestation en 2019
elle va à c'est à dire que tous habitent
et maintenant cette affaire ça vient
vraiment
ce concept race cup ghislaine maxwell
croupit derrière les barreaux depuis 17
mois son procès pourrait durer six
semaines ici geneviève garon
radio-canada new york